.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE PRESIDENT
TOMORROW.
WE ARE FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT
JAMPACKED SHOW, EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THIS SAD SAD
SHOWING ON CAPITOL HILL BY BOB
MUELLER.
CHRIS HAWN, ARI FLEISCHER, AND
WE EVEN HAVE A BODY LANGUAGE
BREAKDOWN ON MUELLER.
AN EXPERT WHO WORKED CLOSELY
WITH HIM FOR YEARS.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE WHA
HE HAS TO SAY ABOUT TODAY'S
TESTIMONY.
FIRST, TRUMP BEATS THE ELITE
AGAIN.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHEN HE WAS APPOINTED SPECIAL
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER WAS
DESCRIBED BY THE POLITICAL AND
MEDIA ELITE AS A BRILLIANT
CHOICE.
CAN GET THERE IS NO MORE
RESPECTED FIGURE IN AMERICAN LA
ENFORCEMENT THAN BOB MUELLER.
HE'S GOT A REPUTATION FOR NO
NONSENSE.
>> HE IS A PRO, YOU WILL FOLLOW
THE FACTS WHERE THEY LEAD.
>> THIS IS BIG STUFF AND MUELLE
IS THE GUY TO DO IT.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE RESOLVED
BY ONE MAN SITTING QUIETLY AT
HIS DESK NAMED ROBERT MUELLER.
>> BOB MUELLER COMPLETED ANOTHE
TOUR OF DUTY.
>> AT THE TIME I MIGHT'VE BEEN
THE ONLY ONE NOT BUYING IT.
>> I AM SICK OF HEARING WHAT A
GREAT PROSECUTOR BOB MUELLER IS.
THEY SHOULD STAND UP AND SAY
LET'S SEE WHERE THIS GOES.
>> I SHOULD HAVE BOUGHT MOTTO
TICKETS THAT DAY.
WHERE DID THIS ALL GO?
WE FOUND OUT TODAY THAT WHEN WE
SAW A MAN WHO WE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO BE WELL-PREPARED WASN'T
.
>> I DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF
ME.
I TAKE YOUR WORD.
I'M NOT CERTAIN OF THE PERSON
WHO ORIGINALLY COPIED THAT QUOTE
.
I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
I CAN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION
WITHOUT KNOWING MORE ABOUT THAT
QUESTION.
>> A MAN WHO WASN'T WELL-VERSED
IN THE DETAILS OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU THE
REASON AGAIN THAT YOU DID NOT
INDICT DONALD TRUMP IS BECAUSE
OF OPINION SEEN YOU COULD NOT
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT, IS
THAT CORRECT?
>>LAURA: MAN WHO HAD TO COME
BACK AFTER BREAKING CORRECT THA
ANSWER.
>> AND WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE
THING THAT WAS SAID THIS MORNING
.
YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T CHARGE THE
PRESIDENTS BECAUSE OF THE OLC
OPINION.
THAT IS NOT THE CORRECT WAY TO
SAY IT YOU DID NOT REACH A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME.
>>LAURA: THAT WAS JUST A SMALL
PART OF IT.
AFTER ALL OF THAT, THE SAME
MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT WHO LAUDED
MOELLER FROM THE START, IT WAS
REDUCED TO ADMITTING THIS ABOUT
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS.
>> IT WAS A TELEVISED DISASTER.
>> I THOUGHT IT REALLY WAS A
VERY INEFFECTIVE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO BE
DISAPPOINTED.
>> IT CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE
DONALD TRUMP IS WINNING.
>> FINALLY SOME HONESTY.
IF ANYBODY CAN HAVE A BAD DAY,
I'M A LAWYER TOO, I WAS INVOLVE
IN A LOT OF WHITE COLOR
INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU DON'T ALWAYS HIT HOME RUNS.
BUT THIS WAS A DAY FULL OF
SWINGS AND MISSES.
AN INVESTIGATION THAT WAS IN
SEARCH OF A CRIME FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
ANYBODY,  BUT RANK PARTISANS
WOULD COME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION AT THIS POINT.
IF MUELLER WAS THE CONSUMMATE
PRO EVERYBODY SAID HE WAS, HE
WOULD'VE USED TODAY TO APOLOGIZ
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THIS
PRESIDENT FOR WHAT ULTIMATELY
WAS A TRAVESTY.
WE WILL NEVER KNOW THE FULL
EXTENT OF HOW MUCH THIS HAS
HOBBLED THE PRESIDENCY OF DONAL
TRUMP.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS, EVEN WITH
THIS ALBATROSS AROUND HIS NECK,
THE PRESIDENT HAS ONCE AGAIN
BEATEN THE ELITES AT THEIR OWN
GAME.